it was on the first day of the new year
that the announcement was made almost
simultaneously from three observatories
that the motion of the planet Neptune
the outermost of all the planets that
wheel about the Sun had become very
erratic algal v had already called
attention to a suspected retardation in
its velocity in December such a piece of
news was scarcely calculated to interest
a world the greater portion of whose
inhabitants were unaware of the planet
Neptune no idea strin ah Mical
profession did the subsequent discovery
of a faint remote speck of light in the
region of the paterberg planet caused
any great excitement scientific people
however found the intelligence
remarkable enough even before it became
known that the new body was rapidly
growing larger and brighter that its
motion was quite different from the
orderly progress of the planets and that
the deflection of Neptune and its
satellite was becoming now of an
unprecedented kind
few people without a training in science
can realize the huge isolation of the
solar system the Sun with its speck of
planets its dust of planetoids and its
impalpable comets swims in a vacant
immensity that almost defeats the
imagination beyond the orbit of Neptune
there is space vacant so far as human
observation is penetrated without warmth
or light or sound blank emptiness for 20
million times a million miles that is
the smallest estimate of the distance to
be traversed before the very nearest of
the Stars is attained and saving a few
comets more unsubstantial than the
thinnest flame no matter had ever to
human knowledge crossed this gulf of
space until early in the 20th century
this strange wanderer appeared a vast
mass of matter it was bulky heavy
rushing without warning out of the black
mystery of the sky into the radiance of
the Sun by the second day it was clearly
visible to any decent instrument as a
speck with a barely sensible diameter in
the constellation Leo near Regulus in a
little while an opera-glass could attain
it on the third day of the new year the
newspaper readers of two hemispheres
were made aware for the first time of
the real importance of this unusual
apparition in the heavens a planetary
collision one London paper headlined the
news and proclaimed Deschenes opinion
that this strange new planet would
probably collide with Neptune the lead
writers enlarged upon the topic so that
in most of the capitals of the world on
January 3rd
there was an expectation however vague
of some imminent phenomenon in this
I and as the night followed the Sun set
round the globe thousands of men turned
their eyes skyward to see the old
familiar stars just as they always had
been until it was dawn in London and
Pollux setting and the Stars overhead
grown pale the winter's dawn it was a
sickly filtering accumulation of
daylight and the light of gas and
candles Shawn yellow in the windows to
show where people were astir
but the yawning policemen saw the thing
the busy crowds in the markets stopped a
gate workmen going to their work the
times milk men the drivers of news carts
dissipation going home jaded and pale
homeless Wanderers sentinels on their
beats and in the country laborers
trudging a field poachers slinking home
all over the dusky quickening country it
could be seen and out at sea by sea men
watching for the day the great white
star comes suddenly into the westward
sky brighter it was than any star in our
skies brighter than the evening star at
its brightest it still glowed out white
and large no mere twinkling spotlight
but a small round clear shining disc an
hour after the day had come and where
science has not reached men stared and
feared telling one another of the wars
and pestilences that are foreshadowed by
these fiery signs in the heavens
Frenchmen Spaniards Portuguese all stood
in the warmth of the sunrise watching
the setting of this strange new star and
in a hundred observatories there had
been suppressed excitement rising almost
a shouting pitch as the two remote
bodies had rushed together and a
hurrying to and fro to gather
photographic apparatus and spectroscope
and this appliance and that to record
this novel astonishing sight the
destruction of a world where it was a
world a sister planet of the earth far
greater than our earth indeed that had
so suddenly flashed into flaming death
Neptune
it was had been struck fairly and
squarely by the strange planet from
outer space and the heat of the
concussion had incontinently turned to
solid globes into one vast mass of
incandescence round the world that day
two hours before the dawn went the
pallid great white star fading only as
it sank Westwood and the Sun mounted
above it everywhere man marveled at it
but of all those who saw it none could
have marveled more than those sailors
habitual Watchers of the stars who far
away at sea had heard nothing of his
Advent and saw it now rise like a pygmy
moon and climbs any food and hang
overhead and sink westward with the
passing of the night and when next it
rose over Europe everywhere were crowds
of Watchers on hilly slopes on house
roofs in open spaces staring eastward
for the rising of the great new star
they rose with a white glow in front of
it like the glare of white fire it is
larger they cried it is brighter and
indeed the moon a quarter full and
sinking in the West was in its apparent
size beyond comparison but scarcely in
all its breadth had it as much
brightness now as the little circle of
the strange new star it is brighter
cried the people clustering in the
streets
but in the dim observatory's the
Watchers held their breath and peered at
one another it is nearer they said
nearer and voice after voice repeated it
is nearer and the clicking Telegraph
took that up and it trembled the long
telephone wires and in a thousand cities
grimy compositors fingered the type it
is nearer men writing an office is
struck with a strange realization flung
down their pens men talking in a
thousand places suddenly came upon a
grotesque possibility in those words it
is nearer it hurried along wakening
streets it was shouted down the frost
stilled ways of quiet villages men who
had read those things from the throbbing
tapes stood in yellow lit doorways
shouting the news to the passerby it is
nearer pretty women flushed and
glittering her the news told jestingly
between the dances and feigned an
intelligent interest they did not feel
nearer indeed how curious how very very
clever people must be to find out things
like that lonely tramps faring through
the wintry night murmured those words to
comfort themselves looking skyward
it has need to be nearer for the Knights
as cold as charity don't seem much warm
from it if it's nearer all the same
what is a new star to me cried the
weeping woman kneeling beside her dead
the schoolboy rising early for his
examination work puzzled it out for
himself with the great white star
shining broad and bright through the
frost flowers of his window centrifugal
centric petal he said with his chin on
his fist stop a planet in its flight
robit of its centrifugal force what then
do we come in the way
I wonder the light of that day went the
way of its brethren and with the later
watches of the frosty darkness Rose the
strange star again and it was now so
bright the waxing moon seemed but a pale
yellow ghost of itself
hanging huge in the sunset in a South
African city a great man had married and
the streets were alight to welcome his
return with his bride even the skies
have illuminated said the flatterer
under Capricorn to lovers daring the
wild beasts and evil spirits for love of
one another crouched together in a
Canebrake where the fireflies hovered
that is our star they whispered and felt
strangely comforted by the sweet
brilliance of its light
the master mathematician sat in his
private room and pushed the papers from
him his calculations were already
finished in a small white vial there
still remained a little of the drug that
had kept him awake and active for four
long nights each day serene explicit
patient as ever he had given his lecture
to his students and then it come back at
once to this momentous calculation his
face was grave a little drawn and hectic
from his drugged activity for some time
he seemed lost in thought then he went
to the window and the blind went up with
a click halfway up the sky over the
clustering roofs chimneys and steeples
of the city hung the star he looked at
it as one might look into the eyes of a
brave enemy you may kill me
he said after a silence but I can hold
you and all the universe for that matter
in the grip of this little brain I would
not change even now he looked at the
little vial there will be no need of
sleep again he said
the next day at noon punctual to the
minute he entered the lecture theater
put his hat on the end of the table as
his habit was and carefully selected a
large piece of chalk it was a joke among
his students that he could not lecture
without that piece of chalk to fumble in
his fingers and once he had been
stricken to impotence by their hiding
his supply he came and looked under his
gray eyebrows at the rising tears of
young fresh faces and spoke with his
accustomed studied cominis of phrasing
circumstances have arisen circumstances
beyond my control he said and paused
which will debar me from completing the
course I had designed it would seem
gentlemen if I may put the thing clearly
and briefly that man has lived in vain
the students glanced to one another that
they heard all right mad raised eyebrows
and grinning lips there were but one or
two faces remained intent upon his calm
gray fringed face it will be interesting
he was saying to devote this morning to
an exposition so far as I can make it
clear to you of the calculations that
have led me to this conclusion let us
assume he turned towards the blackboard
meditating a diagram in the way that was
usual to him what was that about lived
in vain whispered one student to another
listen said the other nodding towards
the lecturer and presently they began to
understand
that night the star rose later for its
proper eastward motion had carried it
some way across Leo towards Virgo and
its brightness was so great that the sky
became a luminous blues it rose and
every star was hidden in its turn save
only Jupiter near the zenith capella
Aldebaran Sirius and the pointers of the
bear it was very white and beautiful in
many parts of the world that night a
pallid halo and circled it about it was
perceptibly larger in the clear
refractive sky of the tropics it seemed
as if it were nearly a quarter size of
the moon the frost was still on the
ground in England but the world was as
brightly lit as if it was midsummer
moonlight one could see to read quite
ordinary print by that cold clear light
and in the cities the lamps burnt yellow
and wine and everywhere the world is
awake that night and throughout
Christendom a Samba murmur hung in the
Keen air over the countryside like the
Belling of bees in the Heather and this
murmurous tumult grew to a clan or in
the cities it was the tolling of the
bells in a million belfry towers and
steeples summoning the people to Sleep
No More to sin no more but to gather in
their churches and pray
and overhead growing larger and brighter
as the earth rolled on its way and the
night past Rose the dazzling star and
the streets and houses were alight in
all the cities the shipyards glared and
whatever roads led to high country were
lit and crowded all night long and in
all the seas about the civilized lands
ships with throbbing engines and ships
with belying sails crowded with men and
living creatures were standing out to
ocean and the north for already the
warning of the master mathematician had
been telegraphed all over the world and
translated into a hundred tongues the
new planet and Neptune locked in a fiery
embrace were whirling headlong ever
faster and faster towards the Sun
already every second this blazing mass
flew 100 miles and every second its
terrific velocity increased as it flew
now indeed it must pass a hundred
million of miles wide of the earth and
scarcely affect it but near its destined
path as yet only slightly perturbed spun
the mighty planet Jupiter and his moons
sweeping splendid round the Sun every
moment now the attraction between the
fiery star and the greatest of the
planets grew stronger and the result of
that attraction inevitably Jupiter would
be deflected from its orbit into an
elliptical path and the burning star
swung by his attraction wide of its Sun
would rush would describe a curved path
and perhaps collide with an certainly
past very close to our
earthquakes volcanic outbreaks cyclones
sea waves floods and a steady rise in
temperature - I know not what limit so
prophesy the master mathematician and
overhead to carry out his words lonely
and cold and livid blazed the star of
the coming due to many who stare did it
that night until their eyes ached it
seemed that it was visibly approaching
and that night - the weather changed and
the frost that had gripped all Central
Europe and France and England softened
towards but you mustn't imagine because
I have spoken of people praying through
the night and people going aboard ships
and people fleeing towards mountainous
country that the whole world was already
in a terror because of the star as a
matter of fact you soon want still ruled
the world and saved for the talk of idle
moments and the splendor of the night
nine human beings out of ten were still
busy at their common occupations in all
the cities the shops save one here and
there opened and closed at their proper
hours the doctor and The Undertaker
plied their trades the workers gathered
in the factories soldiers drilled
scholars studied lovers sought one
another thieves lurked and fled
politicians planned their schemes the
presses and newspapers ruled through the
night and many a priest of this church
and that would not open his holy
building to further what he considered a
foolish panic the star was no star no
gas comet and where it has died could
not possibly strike the earth there was
no precedent for such a thing common
sense was sturdy everywhere school
jesting a little inclined to persecute
the obdurate fearful that night at 7:15
by greenwich time the star would be at
its nearest to Jupiter then the world
would see the turn things would take the
master mathematicians grim warnings were
treated by many is so much mere
elaborate self-advertisement common
sense at last a little heated by
argument signified it's an adult herbal
convictions by going to bed so to
barbarism and savagery already tired of
the novelty went about their nightly
business and saved for a howling dog
here and there the beasts world left the
star unheeded and yet when at last the
watchers in the European states saw the
star rise an hour later it is true but
no larger than it had been the night
before there was still plenty awake to
laugh at the master mathematician to
take the danger as if it had passed but
Hereafter
the laughter ceased the star grew it
grew with a terrible steadiness hour
after hour a little larger each hour a
little nearer the midnight Zenith and
brighter and brighter until it had
turned night into a second day had it
come straight to the earth instead of in
a curved path had it lost no velocity to
Jupiter it must have left to the
intervening gulf in a day but as it was
it took five days altogether to come by
our planet the next night it had become
a third the size of the moon before it
set to English eyes and the Thor was
assured it rose over America and near
the size of the moon but blinding white
to look at and hot and a breath of hot
wind blew now with its rising and
gathering strength and in Virginia and
Brazil and down the st. Lawrence Valley
it shone intermittently through a
driving reek of thunder clouds
flickering with violent lightning and
hail unprecedented in Manitoba was a
thaw and devastating floods and upon all
the mountains of the earth the snow and
ice began to melt that night and all the
rivers coming out of high country flowed
thick and turbid and soon in their upper
reaches with swirling trees and the
bodies of beasts
they rose steadily steadily in the
ghostly brilliance and came trickling
over their banks at last behind the
flying population of their valleys and
along the coast of Argentina and up the
South Atlantic the tides were higher
than had ever been in the memory of man
and the storms drove the waters in many
cases scores of miles inland drowning
holes cities and so great blew the heat
during the night that the rising of the
Sun was like the coming of a shadow the
earthquakes began and grew until all
down America from the Arctic Circle to
Cape Horn hillsides were sliding
fissures were opening and houses and the
walls crumbling to destruction the whole
side of cotopaxi slipped out in one vast
convulsion and a tumult of lava poured
out to so high and broad and Swift and
liquid that in one day
he'd reached the sea
so the star with the one moon in its
wake
marched across the Pacific trailed the
thunderstorms like the hem of a robe and
the growing tidal wave the toiled behind
it
frothing and eager poured over island
and island and swept them clear of men
until that wave came at last in a
blinding light and with the breath of a
furnace Swift and terrible it came fifty
feet high
roaring hungrily upon the long coasts of
Asia and swept inland across the plains
of China for a space the star hotter now
and larger and brighter than the Sun in
its strength showed with pitiless
brilliance the wide and populous country
towns and villages with their pagodas
and trees roads wide cultivated fields
millions of sleepless people staring in
helpless terror the incandescent sky and
then low and growing came the murmur of
the flood and thus it was with millions
of men that night a flight no wither
with limbs heavy with heat and breath
fierce and scant and the flood like a
wall Swift and white behind
and then death China was lit glowing
white but over Japan and Java and all
the islands of eastern Asia the great
star was a ball of dull red fire because
of the steam and smoke and ashes the
volcanoes were spouting forth to salute
its coming above who was the lava hot
gases and ash and below the ceiling
floods in the whole earth swayed and
rumbled with the earthquake shocks
soon the immemorial snows of Tibet and
the Himalaya were melting by 10 million
deepening converging channels upon the
plains of Burma and Hindustan the
tangled summits of the Indian jungles
were aflame in a thousand places and
below the hurrying waters around the
stems were dark objects that still
struggled feebly and reflected the
blood-red tongues of fire and in a
rudderless confusion a multitude of men
and women fled down the broad river ways
to that one last hope of men the open
sea
larger group the star and larger hotter
and brighter with a terrible swiftness
now the tropical ocean had lost its
phosphorescence and the whirling steam
rose in ghostly wreaths from the black
waves that plunged incessantly speckled
with storm tossed ships and then came a
wonder it seemed to those in Europe
watching for the rising of the star that
the world must have ceased its rotation
in a thousand open spaces of down and
Upland the people who had fled thither
from the floods and the falling houses
and sliding slopes of hill watched for
that rising in vain hour followed hour
through a terrible suspense and the star
rose not once again men set their eyes
upon the old constellations they had
counted lost to them forever in England
it was hot and clear overhead though the
ground quivered perpetually but in the
tropics Sirius and capela
and all the Barons showed through a veil
of steam and when at last the great star
rose near ten hours late the Sun rose
close upon it and in the centre of its
white heart was a disc of black over
Asia
it was the star had begun to fall behind
the movement of the sky and then
suddenly as it hung over India its light
had been veiled all the plain of India
from the mouth of the Indus to the mouth
of the Ganges was a shallow waste of
shining water that night out of which
rose temples and palaces mounds and
Hills black with people every minaret
was a clustering mass of people who fell
one by one into the turbid waters as
heat and terror over
came them the whole land seemed a
whaling and suddenly there swept a
shadow across that furnace of despair
and a breath of cold wind and a
gathering of clouds out of the cooling
air men looking up near blinded at the
star so that the black disk was creeping
across the light it was the moon coming
between the star and the earth and even
as men cried to God at this respite out
of the east with a strange inexplicable
swiftness sprang the Sun and then star
Sun and Moon rushed together across the
heavens so it was that presently to the
European watches star and Sun rose close
upon each other
drove headlong for a space and then
slower and at last came to rest star and
Sun merged into one glare of flame at
the zenith of the sky the moon no longer
eclipsed the star but was lost to sight
in the brilliance of the sky and though
those who were still alive regarded it
for the most part with that dull
stupidity that hunger fatigue heat and
despair in gender there was still men
who could perceive the meaning of these
science star and earth had been at their
nearest had swung about one another and
the star had passed already
it was receding swifter and Swifter in
the last stage of its head long journey
downward into the Sun
and then the clouds gathered blotting
out the vision of the sky the thunder
and lightning wove a garment around the
world all over the earth was such a
downpour of rain as men had never before
seen and where the volcanoes flared red
against the cloud canopy there descended
torrents of mud everywhere the waters
were pouring off the land leaving mud
silted ruins and the earth littered like
a storm worn beach with all that had
floated and the dead bodies of the men
and brutes it's children for days the
water streamed off the land sweeping
away soil and trees and houses in the
way and piling huge dikes and scooping
out titanic gullies over the countryside
those were the days of darkness that
followed the star and the heat all
through them and for many weeks and
months the earthquakes continued but the
star had passed and men hunger driven
and gathering courage only slowly might
creep back to their ruined cities buried
granaries and sodden fields such few
ships has had escaped the storms of that
time came stunned and shattered and
sounding their way cautiously through
the new marks and shoals of once
familiar ports and as the storm subsided
men perceived that everywhere the days
were hotter than of yore and the Sun
larger and the moon shrunk to a third of
its former size took now four score days
between its new and new but of the new
brotherhood that grew presently among
men of the saving of laws and books and
machines of the strange change that had
come over Iceland and Greenland and the
shores of boffins Bay so that the
sailors coming there presently found
them green and gracious and could scarce
believe there
ize this story does not tell nor of the
movement of mankind now that the earth
was hotter northward and southward
towards the poles of the earth it
concerns itself only with the coming and
passing of the star the Martian
astronomers for there are astronomers on
Mars although they are very different
beings from men were naturally
profoundly interested by these things
they saw them from their own standpoint
of course considering the mass and
temperature of the missile that was
flung through our solar system into the
Sun on wrote it is astonishing what a
little damage the earth which it missed
so narrowly has sustained all the
familiar continental markings and the
masses of the seas remain intact and
indeed the only difference seems to be a
shrinkage of the white discoloration
supposed to be frozen water round either
pole
which only shows how small the vastest
of human catastrophes may seem at a
distance of a few million miles
[Music]
you
[Music]